russische Medien verbreiten am Morgen
dieses Bild der Anschlag soll ein Loch
in die Fahrbahn gerissen haben der
Verkehr kommt vorübergehend zum Erliegen
die Behörden empfehlen die Brücke zu
meiden Moskau macht ukrainische
Geheimdienste dafür verantwortlich
spricht von einem Terrorakt von einem
Drohnenangriff die von Russland
eingesetzt Regierung der Grimm ergreift
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen
wir bitten alle Touristen in ihren
Hotels zu bleiben bis sie von uns hören
auch ein anderer Teil des Konflikts ist
weiter ungeklärt während in der Ukraine
die Ernte läuft ist unklar ob das
Getreide das Land verlassen kann das von
den Vereinten Nationen vermittelte
getreideabkommen läuft heute aus wie es
weitergeht ist unklar Moskau hat am
Vormittag erklärt das Abkommen werde
gestoppt weitere Gespräche darüber
stehen jetzt auch unter dem Eindruck des
Anschlags auf die Brücke zur Krim
und über das Ende des getreideabkommens
und den möglichen Anschlag auf der Krim
können wir jetzt sprechen mit unseren
Reportern in der Ukraine
und der Russland Korrespondentin für
begabt derzeit in Mainz schönen guten
Tag
beginnen wir mit der Ukraine in der
Ukraine daran wie reagiert die Ukraine
jetzt auf das Ende des Abkommens was
heißt das auch für das Getreide und die
Lieferung
ja die ukrainische Regierung hat auf
diese Meldung aus Moskauer erstaunlich
gelassen reagiert das mag zum einen
daran liegen dass man noch eine
Hintertür für Verhandlungen sieht denn
Russland betonte dass man wenn russische
Forderungen erfüllt würden sofort
augenblicklich wieder in dieses
getreideabkommen einsteigen könne zum
anderen hat sich die Ukraine die über
die letzt über die letzten Monate und
falls seit einem Jahr schon darauf
vorbereitet andere Wege Alternativrouten
aufzubauen über die Eisenbahn aber auch
hier wie in Israel am Donauhafen über
die See das funktioniert auch in
gewisser Weise ganz gut auch wenn die
Kapazitäten nicht ausreichen um die
schwarzen bei Odessa zu kompensieren
dafür reicht's nicht ein Ende des
Abkommens wird die Ukraine immer noch
hart treffen schauen wir zu unserer
Korrespondentin für Russland für begabt
wie begründet Moskau das Aus für das
Abkommen jetzt konkret
also die ausführliche Begründung die
wird lautsprecherin des
Außenministeriums zeitnah veröffentlicht
vermutlich steht dann da eben so etwas
drin wie das Moskau seine Bedingungen
nicht erfüllt sieht wir hören schon seit
Monaten immer wieder Beschwerden die
sich im Kern um eine Sache drehen und
zwar russische Agrarprodukte und
Düngemittel die sollten eigentlich nicht
von den westlichen Sanktionen betroffen
sein de facto ist aber der Handel damit
erschwert weil zum Beispiel russische
Banken ausgeschlossen sind vom
internationalen
Zahlungsdienstleister Swift und ja
moskau sieht da eben hatte vereinbart in
den getreideabkommen das ist da
Erleichterungen geben soll und sie da
die Fortschritte nicht wirklich gegeben
ich denke aber das noch ein zweiter
Faktor eine Rolle spielt warum Moskau
dieses Getreide Abkommen jetzt eben
auslaufen lassen will und das ist das
Verhalten des türkischen Präsidenten in
den letzten Wochen
erdogan hat zum Beispiel ukrainische
Kriegsgefangene an Kiew zurück
überstellt gegen den wollen Willen
Moskau und auch der NATO-Gipfel jetzt in
Vilnius und da sind die Zusagen
sicherlich aus ukrainischer Sicht hinter
den Erwartungen zurückgeblieben aber die
Zusagen waren eben doch mehr als Moskau
sich erhofft hatte und erdogan hatte
sich den nicht in den Weg gestellt
insofern dürfte diese Reaktion oder
dürfte dieses dieses Auslauf des
Abkommens tatsächlich auch eine Reaktion
auf Erdogans Verhalten und ein Signal an
den türkischen Präsidenten sein dann
schauen wir noch mal in die Ukraine es
gab noch eine andere Meldung haben wir
schon drüber gesprochen und zwar dass
die krimbrücke die einzige Verbindung
vom russischen Festland auf die
annektierte Halbinsel durch einen
Angriff beschädigt wurde Russland macht
ja die Ukraine dafür verantwortlich was
ist dazu bekannt daran
also die ukrainische Regierung hat sich
in keiner Weise dazu bekannt oder
veröffentlicht das ihre Geheimdienste
damit verstrickt werden
militärisch ist das für die
Ukraine schon ein Vorteil wenn diese
Brücke zerstört ist denn die russische
Logistik Logistik für die Südfront hängt
schon sehr stark von dieser Brücke ab
und der Landweg durch die russisch
besetzten Gebiete im Süden der Ukraine
der liegt immer in der Reichweite
und Artillerie
aus der Ukraine und unsere Russland
Korrespondentin für Bega derzeit in
Mainz vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung